Freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge ein Tag persönlicher Koch
und heute bin ich ganz ehrlich bin ich
bisschen aufgeregt denn ich habe einen
Profikoch zu Gast eine absolute Legende
direkt aus Frankfurt einen wunderschönen
guten Tag der Bernt ist hier und ich
darf drei Gerichte für ih zaubern ihr
wisst der Bernt ist ein gourm der WN
kocht super deshalb wird es richtig
spannend und ich verwöhne Dich direkt
heute morgen mit meinem take auf einen
strammen Max oh ja also ich dachte das
war eine total lustige Idee ein strammen
Max vom strammen Max Klau ja aber hey
deswegen freue ich mich da richtig drauf
ganzen Tag von dir verwöhnt zu werden
richtig krass danke für die Einladung
ganz genau ganz wichtig wir drehen auch
für Bernt ein Video ich denke mal meins
kommt vielleicht bisschen früher aber
ich führe Bern auch noch durch Köln und
zeig ihm einige meiner lieblingsfpots
wird auch geil schaut deshalb unbedingt
bei Bern vorbei du darfst dich jetzt
erstmal ganz entspannt zurücklehnen du
wirst heute verwöhnt vielen herzlichen
Dank viel Spaß dabei und gibt dir Mühe
ma ich auf jeden Fall ich lass nichts
anbrenen bis gleich B gleich was ist
also mein strammer Max ich habe mir da
ein bisschen was überlegt ich habe zum
einen ein wunderschönes Sauerteigbrot
das Rösten wir schön an ihr kennt das
mittlerweile ich ich finde es gibt kaum
was besseres was man sich morgens in den
Mund stecken kann no sexual als das hier
dazu machen wir eine Mischung aus
verschiedenen Käsen ein Schmelzkäse ein
Provolone ein cheddder Grillen das in
Butter und Olivenöl an machen schönes
Spiegelei und hier drunter ist ein
richtig schöner Rosmarin Schinken Leute
klingt das nicht einfach geil ich habe
wirklich gedacht heute müssen wir
richtig auf den Putz hauen weil für Bern
müssen wir es krachen lassen erstmal
eine schöne Scheibe Brot schneiden nicht
zu dick denn wir machen ein Grill cheese
als Grundlage für unseren stram Max
beginnen wir Pfanne ist schon niedrig
vorgeheizt jetzt gebe ich erstmal ein
wenig Olivenöl an meine Brotscheiben und
wir lassen es heute mal krachen wir
machen heute Olivenöl und gesalzene
Butter Bern muss ich auch sagen ist auch
ein Typ den fei ich einfach unnormal
habe ich beim holre kennengelernt habe
davor schon seine Videos selbst gerne
geschaut also wer nicht kennt definitiv
Auschecken hat einen gastronomischen
background ist Koch geilen Kanal schön
mit Liebe ne schmeckt man auch ob das
hier so mit einem Pinsel oder so mit
Hand so leicht eingestrichen wurde
belegen wir auch schon nehmen wir uns
also ein wenig chedder ist auch alles
nicht zu dick oder zu viel das wird
richtig richtig gut deckeluf Mama mir
und das wird hier so schön rauslaufen
und dann härtet das den cheese wenn die
Butter einmal kurz blubbert haben wir
die perfekte Hitze erreicht und können
unsere Sandwiches reinlegen wir wollen
langsam und sicher die perfekte Röstung
erreichen und das unterstütze ich indem
ich das ganze noch ein bisschen
beschwere von oben sorry wie geil sieht
das denn bitte aus in dieser Pfanne oder
so schauen wir mal es lag jetzt schon
eine ganze Weile drin und der Grill
cheese schmilzt und hat von der
Rückseite ebenfalls die perfekte Farbe
bekommen das heißt wir nehmen es runter
von der Hitze W den Herd ausmachen und
jetzt full Fokus auf unser spiegelein
klingt einfach aber unsere Pfanne ist
leicht am dampfen das heißt es ist Zeit
unser Spiegelei zu machen und straight
reinzugeben mit ordentlich Öl arbeiten
damit es schön knusprig wird schöne
Prise Salz on top und dann frisch
gemalener schwarzer Pfeffer aus dem
Gastgeschenk die löst auf jeden Fall
meine Mühle ab freue ich mich werde ich
mich immer freuen wenn ich die benutze
ich warte jetzt noch bis ich das Ei weiß
gesetzt hat und das Eigelb noch schön
runny ist dann ist es perfekt Schau
schen wir uns noch einmal den
italienischen Rosmarin Schinken an
besser geht's kaum und hier in Köln
kriegt man wirklich die eine oder
andere echte
[Musik]
Köstlichkeit so Bern mein lieber es ist
Zeit du hast dir einen strammer Max Max
Style gewünscht also ganz ehrlich das
ist ja schon wieder so ein Ding ne da
hast du keinen Bock reinzuweißen weil
kaputt machen willst guck
mal SP würde ich sagen Leute wir sehen
uns gleich wieder wenn es an die
Bewertung geht weggehauen mein lieber
Max das Ding ist tatsächlich weiß auch
hier wahrheitet sich das wieder dein
Gespür und deine deine Skills die du
hast sind auf der einen Seite aber auch
diese Produkte zu finden und sie so
zusammenzubringen dass sie sowas werden
stram Max total easy Nummer und dann
kommst Du einfach daher und ballerst so
ein Ding ich sag dir ehrlich mich würd
es nicht wundern wenn es bald in Köln
Restaurants gibt die das so auf der
ganz ehrlich geil dass du das sagst das
macht mich richtig stolz richtig geil
Alter es wird Menschen geben die sagen
den Fettsack schmeckt doch eh alles aber
das gar nicht so ne also das ist
wirklich das kann man nicht besser
machen und wenn man sowas hat was man
nicht besser machen kann brauchen man es
nicht kaputt reden das ist eine 10 von
ze Leute macht das nach ber Mann geil
und jetzt ohne Witz ist die
Erwartungshaltung verdammt hoch und ich
weiß nicht ob ich den Erwartung gerecht
werden kannast selber hochgelegt mach
mal weiter mit dem Mittagessen geil und
für unser Mittagessen machen wir einfach
einen Salat einfach wenn ihr euch das
hier mal anschaut dann wisst ihr dass
dieser Salat alles andere als einfach
ist es ist ein Klassiker der
französischen salatküche es ist der
Salat Nois oder auch nizz Salat und da
ist ein bisschen was von allem drin habe
ich das Gefühl und der Bernt ist auch
ein Schlingel dass er sich den überlegt
hat weil ich habe es noch nie gemacht
und es ist verdammt umfangreich deshalb
fangen wir direkt einmal an wir haben
Bohnen wir haben Tomaten wir haben
Kartoffeln wir haben Thunfisch wir haben
Zwiebel wir haben Eier wir haben
Basilikum wir haben Salat wir haben okay
Salat hätte man sich denken können
pymian Lorbeer karperon Senf sadell
Knoblauch Brühe und vier Töpfe los
geht's als allererstes einmal erhitze
ich den ersten Topf denn wir kochen
zunächst einmal unsere Kartoffeln ganz
wichtig wir starten die Kartoffeln in
kaltem Wasser so werden sie quasi von
innen nach außen schön durchgekocht
alles was ich euch zu diesem Salat sage
habe ich übrigens von Kenji Lope old
einer meiner lieblingsköche genau wir
haben auch ein zwei Twists die Macht
Kenji nicht die werden richtig geil sein
damit die auch wirklich nach was
schmecken müssen wir richtig reinseizzen
die Kochen jetzt das heißt wir können
uns schon mal langsam um die anderen
Vorbereitung kümmern ich fange mit dem
Dressing an und schnibbel als erstes mal
eine Schalotte ganz fein hab hier drüben
auch schon zwei Knoblauchzehen
vorbereitet die kommen zu den Kartoffeln
dazu genauso wie laorbeerblätter einfach
um die noch mehr zu aromatisieren daraus
schneide ich jetzt ganz kleine feine
Würfel das hat einfach den Grund das
kommt unser Dressing das soll quasi
verschmilzen dann haben wir eine
Knoblauchzehe schön fein schneiden jetzt
denkt das war genug der Paste der hat
sich leider geirrt denn wir müssen auch
noch sadellen zu Paste verarbeiten und
dann hacke ich ordentlich drüber wenn
wir auch hier eine schöne Paste haben
dann schieben wir das zu unserem
restlichen wenig Bestandteil wir wollen
nämlich ein paar Karpern fein schneiden
die kommen auch noch dazu so jetzt wird
es Zeit für unser Dressing hab eine
große Schüssel Karpern sadellen
schallotten Knoblauch einmal reingeben
hab jetzt unsere restlichen Bestandteil
dazu ein guter Schluck Weißweinessig
jansinf dann noch ein kleinen Schluck
Wasser purer Geschmack der jetzt hier
gerade drin ist und fange an zu
emulgieren indem ich kontinuierlich
Olivenöl reingebe fine jetzt haben wir
uns verdient das ganze auch mal zu
probieren geil auch wenn man keine
karperan mag die kommen gar nicht so
sehr raus das ist einfach geil Dressing
ist fertig so hier vorne in dem Topf
habe ich einfach ein bisschen Wasser das
Wasser für die Eier kocht jetzt gebe ich
aber erstmal ein bisschen Brühe in einen
Topf da ist schon ein bisschen Wasser
drin hierin kochen wir gleich unsere
Bohnen und damit die noch mehr Geschmack
haben machen wir das ganze in Brühe die
Eier können wir jetzt reingeben ich will
die so ein bisschen flüssig haben ihr
seht jetzt schön die Eier sind nicht
ganz von Wasser bedeckt das ist
überhaupt nicht entscheidend dafür dass
sie geil durchkochen Bohen sind klein
geschnitten ich habe einfach die Enten
entfernt und halbiert schöne schwarze
Oliven halbieren wir einfach einmal und
danach halbiere ich auch noch ein paar
cherryt Tomaten das Wasser für unsere
Bohnen kocht die gebe ich jetzt einfach
einmal hinein ma noch eine Prise Salz
dazu und wir blanchieren die Bohnen nur
das heißt wir kochen Sie vielleicht für
eine Minute und schrecken sie danach
hier im Eiswasser ab damit die schön
grün bleiben ein gewissen Biss haben und
einfach die bestmögliche Bohne sind eine
Minute ist vorbei und man sieht sie sind
wunderschön grün die Eier sind jetzt
fertig gekocht ich gebe einfach ein
bisschen kaltes Wasser dazu auch hier
stoppen wir wieder die Garung und wollen
schauen dass das Ei innen drin ein
bisschen wachsig bleibt Schale kommt
schon quasi von selbst ab einfach ganz
entspannt die Schale abziehen als
nächstes kriegen unsere kartoff das
gleiche treatment so sieht's aus wenn es
fertig ist und dafür schälen wir die
einfach von Hand alles ist vorbereitet
wir geben jetzt schon mal fast alles in
unser Dressing hinein es ist schon
geiles Gericht weil es ist quasi
heutzutage wirürd man das nicht Salat
missois nennen sondern man würde es Bowl
nennen dann nehmen wir uns hier unseren
Thunfisch und jetzt gehe ich einmal ran
heb das um so ent steht uns eben kein
Kartoffelpüree obwohl die Kartoffeln
schön weich sind auch direkt mit der
Hand anrichten sieht ein bisschen
komisch aus aber von selbst entsteht so
dieses geile Bild sehr schön
durchgemischt ist auch hier finischen
wir natürlich mit ein bisschen
bernpfeffer ne frisch gemalen oben drauf
dann kommen unsere Eier zum Einsatz und
jetzt schauen wir mal wie sie geworden
sind noch leicht wachsig jetzt sind wir
noch ein bisschen flüssiger gewünscht
aber wir tun so als wä es gewollt
gewesen dann gehen wir jetzt mit ein
bisschen frischer Zwiebel oben drauf und
oben drauf noch unsere Eier und fertig
ist unser Salat nissois das stellen wir
jetzt Ben vor mein lieber ein schöner
Salat was gesundes zwischendurch meine
Herren da ist das Ding ist der
wunderschön findst du ich finde ihn
wunderschön freue ich mich er ist
wirklich toll du hast aber auch tolles
Geschir und so du hast das perfekt in
szhne gesetzt hier Danke Schön das ist
Restaurantqualität das kann man sehe ich
sofort ja also das kann man sofort so im
Restaurant anbieten und verkaufen da bin
ich mir relativ sicher das verursacht
bei mir sofort Speichelfluss irgendwie
ne und das hast du heute schon zweite
Mal geschafft bis jetzt also max bis
hierin bin ich sehr zufrieden mit dir
sehr gut jetzt kommt aber der große
Moment jetzt musst du das ganze nämlich
probieren ich tu es auch und das der
schöne Moment am Ende ne ja aber jetzt
kann alles was Du gerade gutes gesagt
hast wieder in Luft verpuffen
okay der Teller ist aufgegessen und wir
haben beide gerade so ein leichtes
Grinsen im Gesicht nicht nur weil wir
aufgegessen haben s wir haben
festgestellt dass wir zur gleichen Zeit
zufälligerweise in LA sind nächsten
Monat das heißt vielleicht wenn ihr
darauf Lust habt kommt was gemeinsames a
schreib auf jeden Fall die Kommentare
wenn ich mit dem irgendwas in Los
Angeles machen soll zur Not gehen wir
einfach nur Burger essen ich hoffe dass
auch der Salat dich ein bisschen
glücklich gemacht hat was ist dein
Feedback der ist brutal gut und weil ich
nicht schon die nächste Zähne
daherknallen will kriegst du eine 9,9
wie ist dein Rating abgestuft ist das 0,
kan 9,99 du kannst geht das ja klar das
war für mich wirklich wirklich der
perfekte nitalat ganz einfach so gehört
das gemacht tolle Sachen also wirklich
böchen und es hat alles gepasst wir
können das tot und klein reden in der
Kombi einfach geil weggeputzt
zurückgelehnt glücklich ma mir Bern zum
Glück haben noch zwei D stüchen Zeit bis
zum Abendessen ich habe dir da eine
harte Aufgabe mitgegeben aber so wie du
das hier gemeistert hast wirst du mich
da auch gleich wieder wegknallen ich LEH
mich zurück chill auf der Couch und du
kochst was schönes das sind die
Erwartungen ne jetzt müssen wir Ihen
gerecht werden geil
Alter wir machen Partei leute das ist
eine Vielfalt von Zutaten und ich war
ein Fuchs denn Bernt hat ein Video auf
YouTube in dem er Partei macht und ich
bin so frech und sag trotzdem dass wir
ein zwei Sachen anders machen wir
arbeiten mit Shrimps also mit Garnelen
die haben wir schon einmal geschält und
entdarmt ich arbeite heute mit einer
wogpfanne und nicht mit einem richtigen
wog kann ich leider hier nicht anders
machen geb schon mal ordentlich
Erdnussöl rein und zu meinen Garnelen
gebe ich auch schon mal was Öl und jetzt
kommt der Trick ich habe mir gedacht wie
kann ich möglichst gut ohne die hart
werden zu lassen Röstaromen simulieren
wir geben ein wenig Knoblauch dran und
wenden die darin ein bisschen denn wenn
das Öl gleich richtig schön heiß ist
dann kriegen die sofort diese dunklen
Stellen und ich hole sie raus habe
röstarom habe eine weiche ganele soweit
die Theorie wir haben eine Vielfallt von
Zutaten Palmzucker tamarindenpüree
Fischsoße geräucherten Tofu Erdnüsse
getrocknete shrims fermentiert mit Chili
Eier Mungobohnen in einer kleinen Schale
Schü schon mal bisschen Sojasoße mit
Fischsoße Palmzucker und dann noch
tamarindenpaste rüre ich einmal zusammen
der Palmzucker sich auflöst und wir eine
glatte Soße haben die geben wir am Ende
drüber so hier drüben raucht schon das
heißt die Pfanne ist heiß genug für
unsere
garnel wenige Sekunden von beiden Seiten
und dann gebe ich das auch schon mit
samt des Öls an die Seite wir arbeiten
wirklich mit viel Öl heute bei
asiatische Küche ist wenn man ehrlich
ist gerade mit wck und wird auch immer
ordentlich geknallt ich habe zwei Eier
bereite ich schon mal vor das ist
wirklich so ein Ding es ist nicht ultra
schwer aber es passiert alles auf einmal
deshalb ist gute Vorbereitung wie hier
dass wir alles vorgeschnbbelt haben die
halbe Miete so Pfanne raucht wieder
heißt Karotten rein als nächstes kommen
unsere Zwiebelchen dazu und wir
schneiden unseren Räuchertofu schöne
Würfel Tofu rein als nächstes alles
sollte jetzt langsam schön gar sein
machen wir hier ein kleines Rührei und
lassen die sich hier kurz setzen an der
Seite Sojabohnen hinzu kann man auch
schon durchgehen Zeit für unsere
Reisnudeln die habe ich einfach mit
kochendem Wasser übergossen die gebe ich
jetzt einmal drauf jetzt kommt nämlich
auch ganz vergessen unsere fy Soße
drüber und jetzt werfen wir das ganze
schön durch und es kriegt jetzt schon
diese typische parteiarbe Textur und wir
sind eigentlich schon fast fertig
unserem chinesischen Schnittlauch gehen
wir noch oben drauf bisschen von unserer
fermentierten Chili schrimpaste bisschen
Öl noch rein habe den Knoblauch
vergessen ma ich den hier kurz am Rand
sollte auch in 0, N gar werden noch
schön was von diesem originalen
chiliettig dazu und das kommt wirklich
schön zusammen jetzt kommen die Garnelen
mit samt ihrem Öl wieder drauf Koriander
kommt on top jetzt nehmen wir es von der
Hitze und ich kümmere mich hier drüben
um ein paar Erdnüsse einfach rein in
mser und Stampfen wenn man jetzt hier so
ein bisschen texturunterschied hat
teilweise intakt teilweise schön fein
ist es perfekt palimetteneecken noch
schneiden noch ein bisschen Koriander
zusammenknollen und geb ihm zack zack
zack ich bin so happy bisher mit dem
Wertung gefühlt kann ich nur noch
verlieren weil die sind einfach zu krass
gewesen ich hätte nicht gedacht dass
dass ich so gut wegkomme bei Bern aber
die Gerichte waren auch wirklich geil
ich hat habe auch einen guten Tag heute
also Partei nehmen schön auf unseren
Teller die enttäuschen einfach nicht die
sehen immer geil aus Riese Koriander
drüber die mten Wedges frische
mungobohen sehr sehr geil ich bin stolz
wenn ich das so auf dem Teller sehe
jetzt ist meine Portion einfach drauf
schütten schen wir mal was Bernt sagt
hier ist das Partei und ich sag dir eins
du weißt ich habe mir dann ein Video
angeschaut ich habe nicht alles so
gemacht und ich bin gespannt ob dir die
Änderung gefallen ja oder vielleicht
auch nicht gibt da so einen sehr netten
Mann der ist auch heute bei mir zu Gast
der hat mir was mitgebracht und zwar
perfect bite Leute Bern hat mich nicht
darum gebeten ich mache das weil ich
wirklich geil finde perfect bite Hot
Sauce hat der Bern mir mitgebracht seine
eigene Hot Sauce schmeckt wirklich dumm
gut du hast so diesen paprik Geschmack
du hast eine schöne Schärfe raus falls
du noch ein bisschen Schärf haben willst
benutzt gerne deine eigene hotsuce also
damit wird alles besser aber jetzt will
ich erstmal so hier dieses volle Partei
flavor mit so ein Stückchen Tofu ah du
hast ein geilen Räuchertofu hier mal
weißt du was das Partei auch ist das
kann das kann man ja genau oh wie recht
Du hast oh mein Gott so löffelgericht
eigentlich auch ne also l geht natürlich
nicht aber ich mag immer ich stell mir
immer gerne vor ja genau wie du auf der
Couch sitzt mit dem Löffel und das
weghauen kannst so comfort food ne und
hier sind halt Stäbchen od eine Gabel
das ja wursch wir essen erstmal in Ruhe
auf dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder
Teller ist leer geputzt kurze
trommeleinlage noch e ganz leer ist der
aber nicht hier was denn da los ja okay
komm guck mal was mir direkt auffällt
ist natürlich bei dir geht's über die
Optik hier ne auch wie du es anrichtest
von der das hat das war ein komplett
stimmiges Gesamtbild ne Punkt 1 Punkt 2
Geschmacksbild Partei sofort getroffen
ich denke mir immer bei so einem Gericht
wenn du die Augen zachst i stopft einen
Löffel in Mund und du merkst sofort was
das ist dann ist das schon mal richtig
alles in allem gecrunchte Erdnüsse oben
drauf du hast nichts vergessen du hast
dann alles gedacht Garpunkt perfekt
getroffen Garnelen wirklich toll Tofu
Auswahl auch gut getroffen also das ist
alles in allem war das super stimmig ich
mag es sehr sehr gerne dafür wirde ich
in dein Restaurant kommen und essen wenn
ich sag ich möchte ein Partei haben das
ist ein Zehner Partei was soll ich da
sagen diger das kannst du gar nicht
anders besser machen das schmeckt mir
mindestens so gut wie meins also ich bin
richtig ich bin richtig froh lieber Max
abschließend noch ein paar Worte in
deine Richtung ich habe heute viel Lob
rausgepackt ne du als Autodidakt dass du
mit diesem krassen Content und diesen
Skills die du an den Tag legst bist du
ganz zurecht da wo du bist und das ist
eine riesen Bereicherung für Youtube
also auf jeden Fall Daumen nach oben
falls es noch nicht gemacht hab
Kommentar schreiben ist ja eh
obligatorisch bei uns beiden und Kanal
abonnieren ja das solltet ihr sowieso
weil es Kost nichts und schmeckt gut ich
glaube ich muss jetzt Wein macht's gut
Leute tschüss ciao bis bald